I'm holding probably the most amazing
piece of metal that you've seen in any
of our videos this is the original
mirror from Isaac Newton's first
telescope and this is his actual first
telescope that he made you can see
behind it is the drawings that he made
and the description he wrote in Latin of
this telescope so this telescope has
been with the Royal Society since 1688
there was a bit of interruption where it
was went to an instrument maker so there
may be some later editions but there's
absolutely no doubt that this mirror is
the original mirror if I was a physicist
I'd be telling you about the wonders of
this telescope and the advantage of
using a mirror over lenses so you get
better images but I'm going to tell you
about the metal of the mirror and the
mirror is made from a metal that is
called speculum speculum is not an
element it's an alloy a mixture of
metals and it's a mixture of tin and
copper now you can see the problem
straight away if you're making a mirror
to look at stars and things is that
copper is colored it's red or reddish
colour and for a really good mirror you
need to have it absolutely colorless so
that you see the actual colors of
whatever is in space the moon looks the
right colour it just happens that if you
mix two parts of copper with one part of
tin and just put in a little amount of
arsenic and obviously I'm not in a lab
so I haven't got any arsenic here you
can get a metal which has been known for
perhaps a couple of thousand years
called speculum which gives you a really
nice mirror finish
speculum is the latin word for a mirror
that's not very good mirror well when it
was first made it will have been
polished and it would have been really
good and you can still see the traces of
its polishing so what's amazing about
this is how heavy the metal is copper is
quite a dense metal and so is tin so
this is much heavier than the modern
mirrors that you would have which are
made out of aluminium which is very
light and this mirror fits in the back
here so the light comes into there onto
the mirror and back again and here is
the eyepiece so you look in there and if
you look at Isaac Newton's drawing here
you can see there's a picture of his eye
I don't know whether this is Isaac
Newton's eye or somebody else's so you
can see here's a large ball which is
quite a clever mount that allows you to
turn the telescope in whatever direction
you want and I was quite mystified
because there's a little crown down here
and I wondered why on earth in a
telescope you should need a crown and
our librarian explained to me that
Newton tested his telescope by looking
at some architectural feature in
Cambridge on another building and here
is a indication that he drew to show the
magnification how much bigger the image
was and this is what he looked like to
the naked eye and here's what it looked
like through his telescope so it really
worked I just think it's extraordinary
that I should be touching something that
Isaac Newton should have made himself
but to come back to the chemistry it is
really very interesting that one of the
key features of this telescope was
having the right material to make the
mirror because if you couldn't make the
mirror nothing else was important and so
right at the heart of this fundamental
development in physics was a bit of
chemistry
it turns out that you have to be quite
clever in making this alloy because if
you put too much copper then it's red
and surprisingly if you put too much tin
it's a bit blue so there's a rather nice
sweet spot which depending how much
arsenic you put in gives you just the
right mixture so that the surface
reflects colors faithfully and doesn't
absorb anywhere in the visible spectrum
I'm not a metallurgist but very often
quite small amounts of added material
can affect the way that metals
crystallize and the way that it
crystallizes then affects its surface
properties and hence effects the way
that it reflects light